I miss white conservatives Oh much
rather a trump supporter tell me to go
back to India then a Hillary supporter
tell me she just got back from India on
a spiritual journey won't you find
yourself out of this conversation how
about that bring back the racist guy at
least I don't got to pretend to like
this [ __ ] is it okay I hate it
man white guilt is just so annoying
these white liberals watching them try
to relate to every minority is
embarrassing I'm embarrassed for you oh
my god you're from Mexico uh I was just
there for vehicles
Oh
oh my god I always get oh my god you're
Indian off I just love Indian food
I just love Indian food let me tell you
something no you don't all right that
stuff at the restaurants is not Indian
food that's Indian cuisine Indian food
potatoes and poverty that's what where
are you
that's the menu right there we're not
having chicken tikka masala on a
Thursday I don't know what makes you
think we got it like that but it's not
it's not I honestly think white liberals
are more racist I'm serious man
everybody complains about cultural
appropriation or whatever it's called
you know who's never gonna appropriate
rednecks I grew up in Texas man I never
had some cowboy coming to me like hi let
me tell you something boy let's go get
some chatni lattes man
till you would I [ __ ] love me a
choppy laugh a boy goddamn
throw a little to working it [ __ ] I
tell you what boy love the [ __ ]
novelist a man their words man it's just
a lot it's just a lot
you